improvised explosive devices
there's no set standard on how that's
going to look so every time we encounter
a device it's different and we have to
take all the precautions necessary to
protect ourselves my name is John
Stewart I'm a FBI agent
I'm the unit chief of the hazardous
devices school I started off in the
United States Navy I was an enlisted a
OD tech for 12 years and then was hired
as an FBI agent my primary mission was
to provide support to our state and
local bomb technicians I've responded to
a number of calls those calls resulted
in the discovery of military ordnance
hand grenades improvised explosive
laboratories where people are making
homemade explosives those calls resulted
in us disrupting pipe bombs but they
needed me to dress out in a bomb suit
and go to our range I'm trained and
capable to do that if they need me for
post blast experience to help them
collect evidence we're there to help
them do that because that all falls in
the category of a bomb technician
responsibilities I worked a number of
cases on the international terrorism
side I spent approximately two years in
Afghanistan working as an FBI bomb
technician conducting post blast
analysis and analysis of IEDs or the US
government so if something blew up out
in town we would go out and do a post
blast investigation recover all the
components we could find bring that back
into a controlled environment and then
try to recreate and determine exactly
how that ID functioned and then I was
able to come to the hazards devices
school and become a certified public
safety bomb technician
ie D means improvised explosive device
by the mere term it's improvised and
they come in all shapes and forms they
have to have some type of power supply
or some type of way to get heat into the
explosives they have to have some type
of switch they have to have some type of
container and they have to have
conductors and wires and things like
that when you take an x-ray of an AED
you're looking for the key components
you're looking for the explosive charge
you're looking for the switch and you're
looking for battery power to determine
whether it's an ie D or not there are
two different types of explosives
they're high explosives and low
explosives and those really are based on
the deflagration or burn rate or the
ability for the explosives to change
from a solid to a gaseous state low
explosives burn or definitely great and
high explosives change from solid to a
gas in microseconds when we're dealing
with IEDs some can be a low explosive or
a powder some can be high explosives
military ordnance uses high explosives
inside of it low explosives are
typically seen in some type of contained
vessel like a pipe bomb our pressure
cooker the pressure cooker is a standard
pressure cooker that holds pressure has
a low explosive in it that burns and as
it burns the pressure cooker contains
the low explosive build-up until they
can't contain it anymore and then it
overcomes the pressure cooker and
explodes it's a mechanical explosion
[Music]
as you know the Boston bombing they used
pressure cookers in there everyone who
was able to watch that on TV and see it
through news reports witnessed what
happened so we had several bombs that
grew up on the streets of Boston
following that event there was an
evacuation that occurred they removed
the wounded the bomb technicians then
have to go in and do some threat
assessment and analyze everything left
to determine whether there's any more
bombs in the area as you can imagine
there are backpacks and boxes all over
the street and so they have to go and
threat assess their way through all of
those packages to determine if there's
any more bombs that pose a potential
danger for the public we categorize IEDs
into three different categories we have
victim initiated which means the victim
has to do something to make it go off we
have time which means in a certain
amount of time it's going to detonate
and then we have radio control or remote
control which means someone else is
controlling when that device is going to
detonate the improvised explosive device
presents a number of personal injury
issues of course there's a fragmentation
issue that comes with it the
fragmentation is going to break windows
it's going to penetrate skin it's going
to hurt people it's going to destroy
property every explosion carries a
thermal effect so like a heat wave or a
heat ball or fireball that comes off
there's a potential for things to catch
on fire and burn because of the fireball
that comes off of that explosive and
then there's what we refer to as the
blast wave it's the invisible wave of
pressure that flies out
the blast pressure effects glass it
effects eardrums internal organs and
things like that but we have
calculations that we use to determine
how far to evacuate people to help us
provide better protection from
fragmentation and overpressure the
hazardous devices school curriculum was
originally developed by the Department
of the army
we took the tactics techniques and
procedures that the military would teach
in their bomb techs when they were
dealing with IEDs and we used that same
information to develop our original
curriculum back in 1971 the Vietnam War
was drawing down and bomb technicians
from the Vietnam War were coming back
going to work for police departments in
performing bomb tech activities this
school is designed to Train Public
Safety law enforcement who have no
information about bombs all the
techniques tactics and procedures to be
deployed and used when they're working
on suspicious devices during training
there are a number of key areas we like
bomb techs to leave here with I think
the most important one is their ability
to conduct a threat assessment to look
at something and to try to determine in
their mind why it's there and what's
potentially going to cause it to go off
you have to know electronics so when
you're analyzing your x-rays and you see
certain things in the x-ray you have to
be able to determine what they are you
have to know how to run a robot just in
case you can do it remotely you have to
know how to use explosives because a lot
of the tools they use in the field or
explosively driven tools so you have to
know how to safely handle explosives to
load those tools and place them and fire
them
bomb squads across America receive bomb
calls all the time once their dispatch
receives a call they make a notification
to the bomb squad
the bomb squad then goes through the
scene once there they meet with an
on-scene commander or the individual in
charge and they try to gather some
intelligence what is it where is it how
did it get there how long has it been
there all of those questions are asked
another big important part is is there
an evacuation that has occurred have we
moved all the people out far enough so
if this thing were to detonate before we
made it downrange they wouldn't be hurt
once all of that is taken place there's
a determination do we do this remotely
with robots or do we have to put someone
in the bomb suit if we can perform all
the actions we need with a robot it's
sent downrange to perform x-rays they
can fire tools off of the robot they can
do a number of things that prevents a
bomb technician from having to get into
a bomb suit and actually going downrange
but on occasion there are times when the
robot will not work depending on where
the device is that depending on the
complex situation we have there's
potential for the bob technician to
actually have to get in a bomb suit and
go down and do the initial work make an
assessment of the device perform passive
Diagnostics take x-rays and then place a
disruption tool once that's done
everybody falls back to a safe area and
they perform an action to disrupt that
package so the process of putting the
bomb technician in the bomb suit is
fairly easy but it takes a number of
people to do it so right now they're
putting on the trousers the trousers are
Kevlar and Nomex and they provide
protection to the lower extremities
there's also a back protector that
provides very limited protection to your
back so after the trousers are on the
bomb technicians will afix the
integrated growing protector and that
provides limited thermal protection and
ballistic protection to the growing area
he's now putting on a balaclava that
helps provide protection to the helmet
and absorb the sweat as the bomb
technician is performing his duties the
next piece of equipment that will go on
the bomb technician is the helmet that's
the EOD 9 helmet that's a visor that
moves up and down so when the bomb Tech
is downrange
next to the device he would have the
visor pulled down the next piece of
equipment they'll put on is the jacket
it is a Nomex Kevlar makeup the big
black plate you see on the front is a
Kevlar shield it provides maximum
protection from fragmentation to the
vital organ area they then tighten
velcro around the wrist of the jacket
providing the Bob technician dexterity
with his fingers while he's working on
the left side you will see a control
panel that control panel controls the
fan inside of the helmet to help control
body temperature it also helps the
shield from fogging up and there's
lights on the helmet that the bomb tech
if desired can turn on right now they're
going to raise the collar up providing
protection for the neck area
between the gap where the helmet and the
jacket meet so you'll notice that the
hands are not covered
that's for maximum dexterity the bomb
tech needs to be able to work with tools
and if you put gloves on them it
restricts his ability to use his fingers
and hands once the bomb squad arrives on
scene and they collect their
intelligence they have to determine what
type of approach they make if they
determine that they have to put a bomb
technician down for time on target
there's a couple things that they need
to do so they'll dress the bomb
technician out in the bomb suit and then
they want to walk down range and conduct
a threat assessment and some Diagnostics
of that package one way they conduct
Diagnostics is through their vision what
is it where is it at and why is it
setting where it's setting next thing
they would do is take an x-ray of the
package this machine generates x-rays
that run through the package and
presents an image on a phosphorus panel
the bomb tech would put the phosphorus
panel behind the suspect package and
then generate some pulses with this to
get an x-ray
they'll also bring down some tools to do
some work because we like to minimize
time on target that's time that a person
is standing next to the device and
they'll place those after they perform
their x-ray for a standard general
purpose shot they'll go back and develop
the x-ray and if the x-ray is determined
that it is an actual device they will
fire those tools without ever having to
approach the device again this is a pan
disrupter very common in the bomb
technician world it's a percussion
actuated non electrically fired device
the pan disrupter is a steel tube that
uses shotgun cartridges will fill this
tube full of water will plug it on the
end will put a link shotgun shell into
the end of it and then we use what is
called a breech that has a firing pin
that is then projected forward by an
explosively driven shock wave from shock
to
that way we can fire that remotely and
the bob technician doesn't have to be
anywhere around the package another tool
that's very common is a mineral water
bottle on the interior of this bottle is
a plastic tube that's filled with c-4
explosives this is an omnidirectional
tool so when you detonate the c4 that
water is going to strike the package and
hopefully disrupt the suspect package
that we're working on this can be fired
a number of different ways but typically
it's fired with a primer debt with non
electric shock - a primer debt is
nothing more than a non electric type
blasting cap that is hooked to shock
tube and there's basically an explosive
wave that goes down and initiates the
explosives in the tube one of the tools
available to the bomb technician is a
hydrojet this is a 32 ounce Hydra jet
it's a directional charge which means
it's filled with water this plastic
sheet inside is formed to make a V you
would take data sheet or sheet
explosives and fix it to this V it then
goes back into the Hydra jet this full
of water and it's fired with a primer
Det once it's fired the projection of
the explosives drives the water into a
knife and cuts through suspect packages
since the inception of the curriculum
there's been a lot of change in the bomb
tech community explosives are still the
same
IEDs the devices that we deal with but
of course with computers and being able
to get online and research the
sophistication of those have have risen
most importantly is our tools that we
use to do diagnostics and disrupt IEDs
have increased dramatically our x-ray
systems are some of the best in the
world
our disruption tools are some of the
best in the world and they're all
designed to provide more protection for
the bomb tech Wiley's perform in those
duties which in turn provides more
protection for our public typically
procedures that are trained here at the
hazardous devices school are employed
out in our cities and states across
America it happens often where bomb
squads are notified of suspicious
packages that happens across America
every day there's no playbook that says
if it's this do this or if it's not do
that we have to use the tools and
techniques that we're taught we have to
use a good threat assessment and we have
to work our way through every single
problem we encounter